and you can't write these stories that's
why at night i sit there sometimes and
i'm like what are they gonna knock on my
door
when is the [__] not gonna come with
the dea or the fbi or
somebody somebody because it never
[__] ends
i think of this [__] and i'm like i
gotta go to church on sunday when i go
to church every sunday
i think i go to church because i want to
[__] go to church at 7 30 and
see the priests and the [__] animals
no i go because hopefully they'll
forgive me for all the and i didn't do
nothing bad at least i never killed
nobody
i wanted to i almost killed my ex-wife's
husband when she started [__] with
the kid and stuff and i had friends in
bolder that
let me tell you something about life you
know i'm telling you stories here and
we're [__] around
you know i was a low-level [__] thief
no big deal
but in life sometimes you meet people
that are serious
and that's why i always tell people you
got to be [__] serious
i had a godfather you know the guy that
baptizes you and [__] when you're
born
i love my godfather his name is gabby he
raised me kind of sort of he would come
pick me up on the weekends and take me
to movies
he showed me a gun and a cl he took me
to see dirty harry
and at the end of dirty harry he took me
to eat and he showed me a 44 magnum
he put it on my [__] lap in the car
and i'm like you're a
bad [__]
i mean i love gabby when someone you're
a kid and somebody shows you a gun you
love that [__] man
he was my godfather his mother stood
there and after my mother died i would
see him from time to time he'd give me
money but then he disappeared
and he disappeared for a couple years
you know and i always knew gabby was a
serious guy
and one day i'm hanging out in west new
york and this [__] shows up he's
like how you doing
and i'm like where the [__] you been bro
i really need you you know i really need
i really did
i knew my stepfather didn't get along
and i was kind of pissed at him
so he goes meet me tomorrow let's go buy
you some clothes he bought me a jacket
and all this [__]
and i'm telling my situation and he's
like listen i got a wife i really can't
help you and that destroyed my insides i
was so hurt
so he's like the only i could do is i
sell coke i could give you a couple
ounces a week to sell you know and i go
all right
[__] it so i started fronting half
ounces and
selling them bringing back the money but
i was going to set them up i was going
to get him up to like a pound and then
never come back
so i kept working him working and i'm
telling him i'm like dude i can sell a
lot of coke i sell a lot of coke and
he's like just sell what it's in front
of you
so finally one day i get them for a
quarter pound the blow halloween weekend
83 or 84.
i go over there and he goes you have any
money i got a thousand bucks he goes
take the 4 ounces what are you going to
come back
i'll be back tonight i'm going to sell
them all in one chunk i'll make like 3
000. i'll give you the rest
he says no problem there was no reason i
wasn't coming back
i wasn't even thinking of coming back i
took that blow guy in that car and went
out for halloween i got
[__] up i dressed up like a caveman
and i was giving out bumps to people and
[__]
i was [__] up i stayed up saturday
night i stayed up sunday and i stayed up
monday
just snorting coke in a hotel with
another chick it was dressed that's a
cave woman
and we were just snorting [__] coke
we never oh
so finally she leaves like tuesday
morning i hadn't eaten
i look in the stash there's maybe like a
couple of rocks and some powder
four [__] ounces i'm like [__] i
look at my pocket i got like 100
cash i'm like oh my god what did i do so
i'm walking on kennedy boulevard
i gotta get some nourishment it's been
three [__] days i can feel my bones
i walk over and i s and i hear
wow i'm like what the [__] and last
night turning on the sidewalk and it's a
motorcycle on the sidewalk
and he flips the mask up and that's my
[__] godfather
this guy's 60.
i'm like a 750 with a helmet that you
know like and he's
like i don't want like one of those
things
and he's like where's my money and i'm
like dog you're not going to believe
he's like listen
i need my money i'm like i don't have it
and he goes i need this money for that
we're going to have a problem i'm like i
don't [__] have it
and i just start walking and he starts
chasing with the bike and i start
running and i run through a [__] rose
petal
thing and i got a thousand thorns in me
right like a thousand that was payback
my friend with the [__] cat that was
payback you know
so uh i run and i go into this deli hash
ways and he comes up with the motorcycle
and he goes in and hash ways like i'm
gonna call the police and
he's like i just gotta talk to my god
son he goes dog i need that [__]
money
he goes you came to me like a man i gave
you the [__] thing and
i'm like [__] you you know where were
you when i needed you as a kid you know
[__] you [__] again i wasn't claiming
responsibility
i never seen the [__] after that
never seen him that was uh
october of 84 or something like that
i fall and i do a phony law insurance
thing with this guy
silent and i got 18 [__] grand yes
that's all he did he went around every
day
looking for people to sue if you needed
money right away you take it to a
a supermarket and you drop over pickle
juice and you slip
and then once they come over you say did
i pass out that's a hundred thousand
dollars right there
so i mean that's how many hustles we had
going on so
whatever you need it like sorry i need
300 000 let's cut your finger off you
know what i'm saying like side
what are you kidding me you get like a
half a mil per finger [__] cut bolt
off you got a million dollars i mean
you i got a friend who got 300 g's just
for a tow you know he always had things
like that you're like sorry come on
i just want a little bit of money and i
got 18 grand and i got in the check that
friday listen to this and that sunday
i'm flying out
that [__] sunday i'm flying out of
newark and i take a bus
from 88th street to like 51st street so
my buddy could give me a [__] plane
ride
a car ride to the airport and i'm
sitting there waiting for the bus
with my luggage he pulls up with the
motorcycle
and he pops his mask and he goes you
never gave me that money
he goes we're straight i don't want the
money he goes all i'm gonna tell you is
the next time i see you i'm gonna put
three bullets in you
he goes i already talked to your stepdad
i talked to your uncle in california
i'm shooting you just so you [__]
know
and i was like [__] this
this [__] don't know i'm getting
on a [__] plane right now
he'll be driving around for [__] days
and that's you know it's those little
situations
that it was all a joke for a long time
that's why i always tell people you
better think before you get yourself
like i said i was a regular guy
just [__] minding my business getting
high
you know and all of a sudden i'm
kidnapping somebody
this is how [__] fast it creeps up on
you you know i've heard the stories of
people getting a [__] car
going for a ride and somebody shoots
somebody and there's your [__] life
you know when you go to prison you meet
kids that go out drink and drive and
they [__] hit somebody
and these are nice kids with jobs 100
grand they're doing [__] 10 years
so it's amazing how fast your life could
change over a crime but it's not
your life changing is what you get from
that change
you know prison was a shock to me i
always knew i was going to end up in
prison
i'm not going to deny it but i didn't
know it was going to make me a
a stand-up comic so by
[__] up something good came out of it
you know what i'm saying
so when you listen to these stories
please don't judge me it's just
something i went through some women suck
dicks some guys
experiment being gay whatever you know
this was my experimentation you know
what you listen to
it and you're like this is pretty bad
joey but in the long run it made me a
better man
thank you very much for coming out here
you